die gemeinsame vision zu helfen nenner
müsste man denken könnte einen ja vor
allem wenn es darum geht den flutopfern
zu helfen jetzt haben wir aber einen
fall da sehen wir das eins eben nicht
und es wird ganz genau darauf geschaut
woher kommt denn diese hilfe du sprichst
sinnvoll heckler & koch an so ist es ja
dass das das war ein fall der hat mich
wirklich bewegt und zwar will ja heckler
& koch die rüstungsfirma wollen ja
15.000 euro einige flutopfer spenden
beziehungsweise haben es gemacht hier
sehen wir auf den während den brief
vorliegen schauen sie mal auf diese
passage hier tatsächlich ist das eine
frage die auch wir uns immer wieder
stellen müssen und dies auch tun aber
ein unternehmen wie heckler & koch muss
die erfahrung gemacht haben das ist für
hilfsorganisation schwierig ist eine
unternehmensspende anzunehmen so können
wir auch als bündnis von
hilfsorganisationen die hilfe auch in
anderen ländern mit bewaffneten
konflikten weltweit leisten kein geld
annehmen von firmen denn waffen in
diesen kriegen verwendet werden also da
geht es um den kern der geschichte es
geht um 15.000 euro die sollten
gespendet werden wurden aber abgelehnt
aufgrund dass es sich auch um eine
rüstungsfirma handelt die eben auch
waffen exportiert ja ich muss man sagen
es ist ja natürlich auf einen schlag ins
gesicht für alle mitarbeiter von heckler
& koch also jeder der arbeitet muss
sicher zu fühlen als wäre seine lohntüte
auch schmutzig und es ist ja nicht so
also heckler & koch das darf man niemals
vergessen beliefert ja die bundeswehr
also auch als nach kabul afghanistan
gang sind hatten wir auch rüstung von
heckler & koch heckler & koch beliefert
auch nur bündnispartner von deutschland
und ich will jetzt kein plädoyer für für
für den rüstungskonzern hat aber warum
eigentlich auch nicht also ich finde es
völlig schwachsinnig ist mit den waffen
herstellen so eine in so eine schmutz
ecke stellen das wird ja damit getan
moralkeule stadt fluthilfe super
schlagzeile kann ich mich nur
anschließen rüstet ja auch die polizei
aus ja auch noch dazu sagen eine der
größten und bedeutendsten firmen waffen
hersteller der welt
mit
[Musik]